ici dans le quartier les après-midi se
suivent et se ressemblent pour certains
jeunes déscolarisés
l'ennui est devenu l'unique compagnons
de route je me lève le matin j'ai ici le
ballon je vaux grecque
je reviens je regrette je reviens et on
galère sur un bon je galère je reste sur
un banc j'apporte la lui passe les
jeunes que nous avons rencontrés place
saint paul sont unanimes la fermeture du
centre social samira il y à 18 mois a
fait beaucoup de mal aux quartiers
aujourd'hui la rue est devenue leur seul
terrain de jeu nous y'a rien nous nous
les jeunes en arrière en baoulé qui
fasse quoi à la fin ils sont là dans le
quartier et galères et après voilà c'est
que parfois quand il ya rien à faire bas
après on commence à faire un commence un
peu à faire n'importe quoi
s'il y aurait des activités vous pensez
vraiment que tu sais je ne serai là
ouais ça ça m'inquiète parce que juste
là pour moi et a pas d'activité rien
alors imagine pour les imaginer pour les
petits qui viennent si a pas d'activité
après vont grandir après vous commencent
à cramer les voitures et tous et après
ben ça va je suis un quartier mort sans
lieu de rencontres voilà également ce
que les anciens disent aujourd'hui est
un quartier comme ça n'a pas de salle
des fêtes on voit les gens quand ils ont
une fête à faire avec leurs grandes
bassines mettre dans le coffre pour les
jeunes c'est rue pour faire lé en fait
et rien essayé sur place et un échange
aujourd'hui avec la mairie sur ce qu'on
peut faire dans ce quartier et il ya des
réunions mais ce que les gens constate
c'est qu'on ne vient pas consultés ont
bien informée dix mille habitants et
parmi eux des familles monoparentales
souvent en difficulté qui démissionne
aujourd'hui rétablir le calme
l'objectif d'une poignée d'adultes qui a
décidé de raisonner les jeunes du
quartier